[Music]
throughout the years planet coaster has
greatly expanded the roster of scenery
pieces its players can utilize many DLCs
and free updates have fastly increased
the artistic capabilities of the game
but despite all this there is one thing
I'd like to call attention to it's not
the pieces that enable or constrain your
creative expression and to illustrate
this notion I've selected what I think
to be the most primal raw and pioneering
piece of planet coaster the wooden plank
specifically the 2 meter version and
today I'm gonna try to build a house
using exclusively this piece
[Music]
so how's that for a very traumatic
intro basically this video doesn't
entirely come out of their left-field I
have to say you might have noticed that
I didn't release an April Fool's video
this year and I usually cannot contain
myself when it's April Fool's and I
always want to put some weird stupid
idea of this year though my idea was to
build an entire building out of wooden
planks but unfortunately I wasn't able
to finish it ahead of time so really all
I had was about a 45 minutes gameplay
section where I was trying to make this
work and that's what you're currently
looking at but this is just a really
small part of the video the rest is
something that I recorded today when I
got back to the idea and the reason that
I got back to the idea is partly thanks
to Rudy my dear old friend really been
Kamel you guys probably all know him by
now he sent me a message with one of his
new wacky ideas to make a video series
which is kind of an ode to some of the
original pieces in planet coaster this
is becoming quite an old game it's
upwards of two years old now and he
remembered the time before all of the
DLCs and free updates when we were all
trying to break this game which had very
few pieces at the time by arranging them
in such a way and using chimneys as
pillars and putting windows upside down
to try and make all kinds of new things
and he wanted to make an ode to some of
these original older pieces which don't
see as much use which nowadays anymore
but really show just how much
flexibility this game has and just how
much you can really do with this game at
times it's pretty much a 3d modeling
program and I'm pretty sure the devs are
even making some conscious decisions not
to go too far with this because things
are already becoming pretty ridiculous
as it is and I figured it would be a
good time to revive this old video
because it pretty much exactly fits what
Rudy was thinking of I don't know if
he'll release any more videos on this
I just shortly sentiment update
that I'd be releasing this video
sometime soon but I'm not sure how
likely it is that he'll make any videos
on his side although I do remember
having some conversations about certain
pieces that could be used for this kind
of idea but for now I'm just taking two
wooden planks I'm not really sure what
else I am really going to do with this
in the future I thought it was also just
a really fun exercise because not only
does it show off how flexible planet
coaster is and how many of these all
pieces that aren't even from any of the
DLCs or even from the free updates I can
do so much but it also really shows well
how much creativity you need I guess
it's it's a nice artistic exercise to
try and make something out of just a
single piece because especially with the
recent updates I've been doing less and
less of the crazy weird
placements of pieces trying to make them
work in ridiculous ways which always was
kind of a fun puzzle to do back in the
day so this is just a fun exercise that
feels a bit more like some of my earlier
playthroughs at least for me so it's
actually updates you on what I'm
building you can probably tell from the
thumbnail what this is going to look
like I decided to go for an Alpine style
kind of Swiss Chalet style very much
Jaeger horn ish building just because
that fits the texture of this wooden
plank piece the most I think because
these buildings are mostly wooden so I
do think it's a very practical idea to
make a mostly wooden building that said
I am trying to imitate some other things
with this piece so I'm trying to go for
some stucco walls with the white pieces
over here I'm adding some cornerstones
this sort of we'll see how that works
when the final products is in place and
also of course this is the roof which I
haven't really talked much about which I
haven't said anything about actually but
it's one of the the most interesting
pieces because it was quite difficult to
make the roof work I actually did this
for some of my earlier series including
Necker Park where I made roofs
door pieces but when you make a roof out
of pieces which are much larger than
actual roof tiles and you're trying to
make them look like roof tiles there are
all kinds of parts which you need to
hide so with this roof I had two
slightly inclined all of the wooden
planks and overlap them in a sort of
weaving pattern to make them look like
single wooden shingles which the texture
works alright for for sure but the shape
is quite hard for things like this and
very similarly these corner stones had
to also be inclined slightly so I had to
just get rid of the angle snap and very
slightly rotate them kind of sink them
into the wall to get the size and shape
that I was looking for but all together
I think it works out quite well and then
the rest of the details are of course
mostly Wooden's that's a bit easier as a
lot of timber work going on which are
just the wooden planks nothing changed
there and then some details but really
aside from the windows also which I
decided to use black blanks for I
couldn't come up with anything better I
think a bluish color wouldn't work very
well for the texture so I'm trying to
hide these windows as much as I can but
I'll add more detail to that later to
make them look a bit more realistic but
yeah aside from that the rest is all
just wooden planks this railing was also
quite interesting because as I'm going
for a kind of southern Germany
Switzerland
Tyrolean kind of building I want to have
one of these typical you know balconies
that go around the building which
overhang quite a bit just because that
very much carries the look of this kind
of architecture but these planks are
kind of big even though I took the
smallest length piece basically for
flexibility P reasons because making an
entire building out of the four meter
plank would be even more difficult but
still you don't want to have a
balustrade that's two metres tall so I
ended up going for that sort of cross
design to make sure that I
a railing which is about 1 meter tall
which i think is very fair for a balcony
there are lots of other areas where I
had to hide parts of planks inside the
building to make it look a bit better
like for instance those those details on
the overhanging top floor of the
building and also the window details
which I just added
I added some lighter wood on the window
frames just to make them look a little
bit more like windows and hide that
weird black texture which doesn't look
that well for a window but it's just
about the best thing that I could come
up with now adding to this part of the
building we basically have the main and
the biggest part of the building in
place and now I'm going for a smaller
side in a different direction I always
really like these kinds of l-shaped
compositions of buildings where you've
got one sort of main mass and then a
smaller one to the side and they can
choose scour detail from there because
it's pretty much a formula that always
works at least I always really like it
you do always very much need a strategy
where you where you try to figure out
what your main mass of the building is
going to be I think I always get very
confused by buildings which are very you
know heavy on one side and then very
small on another side I don't know it's
it's a certain composition idea that you
want to make sure that you want to have
the focus of the building in one place
be it very symmetrical in the middle
with some kind of dome or you know a
building has a center of gravity in a
sense I guess it's hard to explain it
giving it a building a sense of balance
can be really difficult and for me
having a big mass pointing forwards with
most of the attention and detail put
there with a smaller one to the side
pointing in the opposite direction works
quite well and I just really like this
kind of composition especially from the
one angle which are mostly be showing
the building off from because I have to
be honest that's just the best looking
angle for this building but yeah that's
just the overall idea behind this
building
very simple I didn't want to go to you
know out there with the overall design
of this building it's really just in the
details that you know I'm trying to be
creative here and make all kinds of
details out of just a wooden plank piece
so here we have the wing of the building
with a slightly different roof this time
it doesn't have that little if it's top
and also we have a smaller less inclined
roof on the side as an overhang to make
some kind of nice little area there I'm
not entirely sure what to do with it but
it just feels right there and I'm just
copying over a lot of the details to the
side of the building as well also and
this is something that I always like to
do the top floors of the buildings or
the top floor of the building will be
wooden and then the bottom floors will
be with stone details but this goes for
any height of any particular part of the
building so because this part is one
floor lower the part where it starts to
become wood is also one floor lower so
we just have one floor with the stone
cornerstones that's that's a very Leonys
me sentence and with the the main
section we have two floors with the
stone cornerstones that probably sounds
like I'm explaining the obvious here but
yeah it's just something that I thought
it's worth pointing out it's something
that I like doing a lot and I don't
think I've ever really called any
attention to it so might as well here
also I've forgot to do this for some
time of the time lapse but I thought I
was funny to actually keep my inventory
tab open with just that wooden plank
showing I think in hindsight and the
time lapse it looks pretty funny even if
it's just such a stupid minor detail
I'll say though if there's one advantage
to making an entire building out of just
one piece it's that you never have to
search for pieces and you never have to
wait for the scenery tab to load new
pieces or anything
whenever you want to start building
something you just grab one of the
planks or you select the plank in the
menu down there and start building so
you can focus 100% on building no matter
how annoying it might be to make things
out of just a wooden plank and as you
might be able to notice I'm mostly
actually copying things that have
already built because for every detail
that I'm adding I really need to make it
first so I need to make a window first
out of the planks or make a balcony
first and then from that point onward
I'm just copying them over for any new
parts of the building now most of the
structure of the building is actually
already in place here so I decided to
get to some of the details firstly this
flower planter I guess these would be
planters because these alpine buildings
tend to have a lot of flowers on their
sides I do have to say I'll cheat a tiny
bit because even though everything on
the building that structural will be
these wooden planks I do want to add
some details mostly foliage that aren't
blanks just to add these flowers on the
balconies and stuff which I hope you'll
forgive me for it's kind of like
cheating I guess because it means that
the building isn't 100% wooden planks
but really it's nothing structural or
attached to the building that will be
non planks so anything that is
permanence on the building is going to
be blanks or really anything that is
part of the structure of the actual
building is going to be blanks and then
all of the other stuff is really just
added in hindsight now I'm also adding a
little Tower I decided that I wanted to
add a small spire because I like spires
but I wasn't too sure where to place it
actually I was thinking of the lower
area first but not that felt kind of
unbalanced so I'll figure that I'll
figure out a place for it later
but yeah it's just a very small spire
because I can't do too much with this
thing because again I'm
that blanks which means that I can't go
all out on the shape especially because
well making a tall and thin spire out of
these blanks you would quickly start to
see where the blanks start falling apart
and moving into each other in weird ways
so it has to be kind of a small stump of
a spire just to make sure that it
maintains a clean look and we don't get
blanks sticking out in weird places see
it's not the most visually interesting
addition to the building but I think it
works out quite well and I eventually
figured out this place on the side of
the the main part of the building here
where to me it felt like it was balanced
enough and really actually kind of
sitting on the the center of gravity of
the building and then also because this
part of the building felt a bit empty
I'm adding a small dormer which is
really simple but just adds a bit of
detail to the roof also because there's
not a lot that I can add to these roofs
because most details you can't really
make out of wooden planks I did decide
to make a chimney though in fact I made
two chimneys with wooden planks for the
top part and then also wooden planks for
the lower parts where I made the lower
part the colour of the walls to try and
get the stone chimney with a smaller
iron top parts look which I think works
out alright in this case I'm still using
shyguys alpine village from
rollercoaster tycoon 3 as a guideline
for what these pieces are looking like
which is something which now is over ten
years old I think and from a really old
game but it's still very much relevant
and it's still very much for me
reference for what kind of pieces you
can add to this kind of building in this
kind of theme so yeah I'm finally ending
the flowers into their their respective
flower the thing is yeah I guess these
are planters another window boxes I
think anyway whatever their official
name is that I lost you know these
things that allow flowers to be put on
the side
looks absolutely awesome and yeah I'm
just quickly rotating and moving some of
these flowers as well just to make sure
that they're not all in the same
position so that they don't look too
unnatural and I'm also using some
smaller flowers for the flower beds on
the lower floors just because there's a
little bit less space there but also
because I don't want to completely make
the the railings invisible because I
thought the X shaped railings actually
look quite cool I really kind of like
the look of them they're a bit unusual
and you can definitely tell that I was
trying to figure out a way to make this
work with wooden planks but I do think
if it's the look of the building and
here I'm really done at this point with
the building itself and I'm just adding
some loose items around the building so
really nothing permanent
just some flower baskets and planters
and barrels and crates and stuff like
that so just loosely scattered stuff and
some foliage but I think it helps you
know give a context to where this
building would be and it helps make the
building look a lot better so for that
reason I am also going to build a small
forest around the building just to give
you a bit more of a realistic setting
for the building and I'm keeping all of
this very simple I'm just building one
small section of a forest with some pine
trees and some palm trees on the bottom
as ferns actually which I think looks
alright and some other small shrubs as
overall greenery so really simple here
but I think it helps make the setting
for this building quite well and then
this open space in front of the building
to kind of be the area where you're
looking toward the building and to help
me actually get some good camera angles
to shoot this building from so yeah
that's it for this time-lapse I'm quite
happy with the end results I hope you
guys enjoyed this time-lapse but I'll
let the cinematic footage speak for
itself see you guys hopefully on some
other more normal video oh I swear I'll
try to finish some of my other series
I'll try not to keep being distracted by
other random ideas but I really wanted
to finish this one because I thought it
was really fun and something I hadn't
seen before
bye guys
[Music]
[Music]